[Music]
we love you we love you lemon
oh
i'm going to be bitter forever
you get a phone call and they're like
lemon do you want to be part of this and
your immediate reaction is
no and then i was like you know what
why don't i just go on tv again
when life gives you lemon lemon gives
you life
i love
drag and i love what i do and i love
drag race and i was like you know what
what's the worst that could happen
i think the true worst that could happen
would be just not going so you walk into
the work room on the first day you of
course have no idea which other drag
artists are there who gave you that oh
i can't believe they're here failing i
wasn't like afraid of anyone just
because i'm like i know what i'm capable
of and
it's a lot
drag has no quantitative skill set what
you love and what i love are going to be
completely different you've found so
much success since canada's drag race
season one ended you of course were
featured on priyanka's come through your
verse on that song
has just gotten so much praise because
you are a wrath queen it's like that
necklace
me
leaving
priyanka are super super close she's one
of my best friends on the entire planet
and like
to get to share something like that with
her we have really just cemented our
place in global drag and in you know
drag race like forever we did
[Music]